[Music]
welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay and we
have another excellent show for you
today but before we get into it uh Lind
what's on your mind fat bear week yes
it's over it is we have a winner it's
128 gracer I love her I commented on her
as I saw her live reveal on the last
episode at the end um she looked great
this year and it's her first win which I
am really excited about she beat second
place 32 chunk who is also very large
and a male bear U but she beat him by
more than 85,000 votes which is like a
pretty big Landslide cuz I think they
were like a total of maybe a little over
a 100,000 votes yeah she she took him to
the cleaners I think it was I think it
was like
85,000 or uh uh no no sorry I I think it
was
like no it was more than 100,000 votes
like she got she got a little over
100,000 votes yeah I think it I think it
was like 120 something to like 40
something yeah yeah yeah um but since
she won I wanted to look up a little bit
about her personality I've been reading
all the news articles about her and
wanted to share uh so she was a
particularly defensive Mother Bear she's
been known to attack larger male Bears
to defend her Cubs and some larger Bears
will actively avoid her because of this
Behavior which I just find very amusing
like she's just dominant in all ways so
she raised and defended her Cubs like
her Cubs are um not with her anymore she
didn't have any spring Cubs uh so she
spent this summer as a single empty
nester bear just living her best life
fishing and eating salmon and I guess
just scaring the
males
and uh I also wanted to just share this
tweet from the official cat my National
Park account that announced her win like
this is this is just High art the Gutsy
Girl grounded the guy with a gut 32
chunk proved his prominent posterior was
worthy of a whopping win but in the end
chunk got Grazer let's Crown Our Queen
that's thicker than a bll of oatmeal 128
Grazer well congrats to her although I
must say
as a longtime 128 Grazer fan and you can
check the tape on that our first fat
bear week episode what what was that
probably three or four years ago uh I
came out in support of 128 Grazer and
you know so it it'll be like it'll be
like if you were a Warriors fan in like
2013 and then suddenly they start
winning and people are like M yeah I've
I've always I've always been a fan of
these cats like no you weren't no you
weren't you didn't you didn't suffer
through through the and like the 9s and
all of the dark times and that's how I
feel as a graser fan I I think that
there will be a lot of fair weather Fans
Say wagon oh yeah like I I loved 128
graser this whole time they don't know
what it was like to Journey Through the
Wilderness over these last few years um
but ultimately it's hard to get that
upset because she won but they all
deserved it you know like they all got
so fat this is we're so happy for them
this is a i I think a participation
trophy in the very best sense of the
word in that uh at the end of the day
you have a whole National Park full of
fat bears and uh they need to be fat so
it's good it's so good all right uh
let's uh let's get into the show in a
second but before uh just up top let's
do some quick
plugs yes if you're enjoying the show
please take a minute to leave us a
five-star review on Apple podcasts or
wherever you're wherever you listen to
the show
uh if you're not enjoying the show
please just keep that to yourself on
today's
episode we cover
topics thanks Greg on today's episode we
cover topics related to training
programs muscle growth and nutrition
plans if you want personalized advice
and ongoing support on topics like that
consider hiring a stronger by science
coach they can design a training and
nutrition plan that's personalized for
your goals and then provide one-on-one
support to keep you on track deal with
any challenges and roadblocks that come
up along the way you can learn more at
Stronger by science.com coaching and
that's where you can also submit like a
short application um I review all the
applications and then we'll help you get
matched with one of our excellent
coaches if you want to purchase
supplements from a reliable source and
support the podcast at the same time buy
from bulksupplements.com and use the
code SPS pod to get a 5% discount and
they have such good prices I mean
they're already what probably 30 40%
cheaper than buying from a non-
wholesaler so that's that's effectively
a 35 45% discount if you if you think
about it that way sure another great way
to support our work is to try macro
Factor our macr tracking and diet
coaching app uh we just released new
widget features for your home and lock
screen on macro factor and they are
killer I wasn't a widget person before
this like I didn't understand um why all
of our users kept asking for widgets all
the time but now I have widgets like
everywhere on my phone showing all my
nutrient targets and my progress on both
my home and lock screen uh overall like
we truly believe that this app is the
best one out there for macr tracking and
we'd love if you give it a try and see
for yourself use the code SPS during
sign up and you'll get a 14-day free
trial you can download it from the App
Store and Google play or learn more at
.c absolutely and if you would like to
stay up toate with all of the research
coming out that is relevant to strength
and physique athletes and coaches uh you
should check out the research review
Mass which stands for monthly
applications and strength sport uh you
can learn more about that at Mass
resesarch review.com uh there's a lot of
good stuff coming out every month
there's also a very thick and extensive
archive uh and in fact in answering one
of the questions on today's show I I
refer to one of my old Mass articles um
so yeah if you'd like to check out that
article or anything else coming out uh
you should check out Mass if you'd like
to stay up toate with the general
Stronger by science Cinematic Universe
and in particular the podcast uh you
should join our Facebook group and
subreddit that's reddit.com rstr
Stronger by science and stronger by
science community on Facebook
um specifically for Q&A episodes uh when
we are putting out a call for questions
either generally or just on a particular
topic um we will post reminders in in
the Facebook group uh if it's going to
be questions about a particular topic
that is where we will let people know um
and yeah it's uh it's fun people Good
Times uh join the communities and uh if
you would like to stay up to dat on the
cont content we're put we're putting out
you should check out and subscribe to
the stronger by science newsletter uh
and it's it's good stuff like we're
sharing informative stuff with you every
other week um it's not just a bunch of
spam and promotions and trying to sell
you like it is uh almost
exclusively just good highquality
content uh so you can check that out at
stronger byci
docomo or a link to do so will be in the
show notes and finally uh if you have
questions that you would like us to
answer on the podcast record a voice
clip uh 30 to 60 seconds and email that
to podcast at stronger science.com if
it's a short question and it's under 30
seconds that's totally fine if it's over
60 seconds we're not going to listen to
it so don't do that um but yeah let's uh
let's get into it so this is going to be
an all Q&A episode and if it goes well
uh and you guys keep submitting good
questions we may do more of these moving
forward uh thinking back about the
history of the podcast we used to do
more Q&A episodes and they went over
well and people liked them uh and we
stopped doing them for some reason which
honestly I don't even remember why but
it's it's fun to go back to to that like
it's it feels like Feels Like Coming
Home in in a way um and also like just
for kind of my own I guess insecurities
I enjoy q& a episodes cuz like I'm like
I'm always like reading and learning
about stuff and I never know the extent
to which my interests overlap with
audience interests and so like when
we're coming up with with topics for the
podcast on our own you know like
sometimes we know something is going to
be a smash like it's very timely like
like the aspartame episode for instance
like that's what everyone was talking
about like that that was a no-brainer
but other s I'm just like hey this is
the thing I currently find interesting
will other people find find it
interesting and like yeah sometimes they
do sometimes they don't um so the thing
with Q&A episodes is at minimum I know
at least four or five people will like
the
episode because uh we're we're answering
their question yeah um and like I'm also
just not on social media very much at
all anymore um so yeah like I I
genuinely don't know know where the
chatter is and like what people are
talking about what they want to hear
about um so I I think like the Q&A
format helps with that like if if
there's something that people are
talking about and you're you're
interested in rake or what the research
has to say about something um the the
Q&A format is a good way to bring that
to our attention because there's there's
a pretty decent chance that we would
just miss entire like swads of discourse
otherwise defitely especially because so
much of the discourse is on Tik Tok now
and neither one of us has spent any time
on Tik Tok yeah no I learn about Tik Tok
Trends through
newsletters and
other much older ways yeah yeah I mean
I'm I'm on Twitter so like I see Tik
toks that like break containment and get
posted on there right um and I hear
people like reference them on podcast
but so so yeah like there there is just
a lot of discourse that we miss and so
yeah if you want if you want to fill us
in uh and say like hey people are
talking about this what do you think um
yeah we love to address that on the show
so um so yeah let's uh let's get right
into it here is our first question for
the
day uh macros I get it I understand what
they are I understand why you track them
but are macro targets expected or
supposed to be hit squarely on the head
or is it supposed to be a range is it
okay to go a little under is it okay to
go a little over should you aim for
exactly the targets or what what what's
what's going on here can you help me out
please thank you yeah so we hear this
question a lot mostly from people in the
macro Factor groups yes um it's pretty
common for people to recommend that you
hit all of your Macros squarely on the
head or if there is any allowance for
there to be for it to be pretty small
like you know within 5 to 10 grams um
but Greg we've talked about this and it
seems like if you're not a bodybuilder
trying to get exotic levels of lean it
doesn't matter so much if you hit all
your Macros squarely on the head like
maybe you focus on protein maybe you
focus on overall calories you try to get
relatively close to your carbs and your
fat but it's definitely not something to
stress stress about right yeah yeah I I
fully agree with that um and I actually
addressed something like not this exact
question but something quite related to
it uh in episode 103 of the podcast
which will uh which will be linked in
the show notes um the segment title was
mis applications of popular weight loss
advice and so yeah like the the idea
that if you are tracking macros for the
purpose of trying to lose weight gain
weight manipulate body composition
whatever uh the idea that you need to
hit those numbers with extreme levels of
precision and if there's any wiggle room
like it's small like ah you can maybe be
5 g under like 8 G over on carbs but
like you need to be very very close to
that number that is a recommendation
that primarily derives from the
bodybuilding Community where I think
that style of macro counting does make a
lot of sense because essentially you are
pursuing
an extremely challenging goal like your
your body your body does not want to be
that lean yeah no like when when you're
getting close to like four or 5% body
fat uh your body is fighting you every
step of the way and so you know it it
might take a more um precise approach to
your to your diet to to be able to get
that lean while maintaining as much
muscle as possible um you're also just
dealing with thinner margins like for
instance there is a certain amount of
fat F that you need to consume to not
wind up with hormonal issues uh uh
absorption issues with fat soluble
vitamins Etc um but also you want to be
able to still consume some carbs to fuel
your your intense resistance training
workouts um and when you're trying to
get super lean and calories are super
super low those two things can come in
Conflict right like uh if your fat
Target is like right at the bare phys
phological minimum you need to consume
um it's bad to go under that by like 15
G cuz especially consistently cuz then
you might run into problems but if you
go over it by like 15 G now suddenly
your carbon take might go from like 100
gram a day to like 60 and then then
you're not in good shape for your
workouts um so yeah like it it makes
sense in that context but if you're not
if you're not pursuing a goal that has
you on super low calories either trying
to get super lean or trying to lose
weight super fast which we also
typically wouldn't recommend um just
that the the physiological benefits of
prec of that level of precision largely
go away yeah and the other factor in
play is that with bodybuilders it's a
very time-based goal like you need to be
absolutely peeled on one particular day
and if you kind of get off course like
you you're track your Macros you're
doing pretty good but like you go over
from time to time you're still losing
weight you're still making progress
towards your goal for 99% of us that's
totally fine but if you're if you reach
a state of being absolutely peeled 4
weeks after your show well guess what
you weren't peeled on the day of your
show and so like that's like that that's
a negative outcome for a bodybuilder but
like a perfectly acceptable outcome for
anyone else who's not planning on
stepping on stage in a speedo right um
so yeah like for for most people most of
the time I don't think you need to be
all that precise uh like you mentioned
if for most people I don't even think
you need to be that concerned with your
carbon fat targets like unless you're
pursuing some type of diet that has your
fat intake very close to kind of the
minimum level that you need to just
sustain normal physiological function um
or unless like yeah you you need to
train really hard for whatever reason
but
are going be low outside of those
considerations I just don't think it
matters very much you know like if you
have like 1,500 total calories that are
going to be devoted to fat and carbs and
you go 1/3 fat 2/3 carbs or 2/3 fat 1/3
carbs like whichever way you're going to
be consuming plenty of fat you're going
to be consuming plenty of carbs for most
goals like it'll be fine like you you
don't really even need to look at the
fat and carb targets
um so yeah just like eat enough protein
get your get your calories close enough
and you'll be in pretty good shape um
and then like also as I as I kind of
alluded to most people don't have goals
that require a a level of like total
energy intake Precision that would be
required to get super peeled on a
particular day like if you're trying to
lose 10 lbs in 10 weeks or whatever um
and yeah like life happens or or just
like their family get togethers and you
want to eat more for a day or whatever
and instead of losing 10 lb in 10 weeks
you lose 10 lb in 13 weeks it's like who
cares you know like you still have a lot
of Life to Live and if it takes you an
extra 3 weeks because you weren't like
super precise with your with your macro
targets and like went over sometimes
like who cares
like most people are willing to make I
think when you when you put it that way
and it just makes it it just makes it a
lot more sustain definitely I can't
imagine how difficult it would be to try
to hit all my macros right on the head
every day like I track all my food super
precisely and have been doing so for
years but there's probably less than 10
times that I have hit all of my macros
like Square on the head like it's just
calories and protein and then carbs and
fat just kind of fall where they are
yeah for sure and and also like one of
the things that we bring up from time to
time is kind of the idea of uh rigid
versus flexible cognitive restraint
right and approaching well approaching
most goals but that would include diet
goals from a posture of flexible
cognitive restraint tends to result it
tends to lead to better results just
period um but then also better
maintenance of results over time
definitely because like trying to like
like they it kind of depends how you
psychologically process it if if you're
approaching it from the perspective of
like oo this is a fun little challenge
to try to hit all of my macro targets
and like if I do cool give myself a
little pad on the back right if I don't
that's fine like move on with life like
you genuinely don't care um like that
can be fine yeah but a lot of people
approach it more from like a rigid
cognitive restraint perspective where
it's like oh man if I if I did go 11 G
over on my carbs today uh or I was like
six grams under on my fat today has been
a failure yeah that's so sad you kind of
beat yourself up about it you don't need
to do that yeah yeah and I mean yeah one
you don't need to like it's not it's not
serving functional ends for you in all
likelihood uh and two like it does just
make it just makes everything less
psychologically sustainable like right
dieting itself is a stressor you don't
need to make that stress
three times more stressful on a daily
basis um and like I said in terms of
sustainability and kind of maintaining
results long term most people aren't
going to want to eat like that long term
and it's like if you're kind of
dichotomizing how you view days like if
you're close enough it's a success if
you're far enough away like it's it's a
failure um you know like it only like it
doesn't take that long like a week or
two of still doing pretty good with your
diet but being uh like missing your
targets by like 15 20 grams which again
like who cares like that's that's
probably fine you are probably still
making progress towards your goals but
instead of looking at that and saying oh
like I'm doing pretty good but I could
do better if you look at that and say
man I've really up these last
couple of weeks that can easily put you
down the road of like losing
self-confidence losing self-efficacy and
like even though you're doing pretty
good in a general sense like the way you
go about evaluating yourself from that
posture of rigid cognitive restraint
like that can that can lead to burnout
and like giving up on your diet before
you reach your goals in the first place
and certainly not sticking with that
style of dieting for the months and
years that it would take to actually
sustain and maintain the results you you
do achieve yeah um so yeah all of which
is to say if you're a bodybuilder forget
everything I just said like if you're if
you're six weeks out from the show and
you need to be yeah super peeled in 6
weeks they know what they got to do like
hit your numbers like that's it
it makes sense in that context but for
just about anyone else try to be within
like h 10ish perent of your calorie
Target uh try to try to meet whatever
your protein number is just kind of let
fat fat and carbs fall where they may
and uh that'll be fine like that's that
is more than sufficient for most people
most of the time y all right uh question
number
two hi Greg hi Lindsay uh with all the
research we've seen in the past couple
years uh not correlating uh muscle size
to muscle strength all that well uh how
much in general would you say someone
has to have uh a certain amount of
muscle to be able to lift a certain
amount of weight and do you think that
it comes down just to genetics and how
much force a certain amount of muscle
can put out to reach that level of
strength or is it the same for
everyone yeah so there's a common belief
that when you see two people with
similar amounts of muscle and one of
those people is stronger that that
difference all comes down to skill or
like neuromuscular efficiency or
efficiencies related to muscle Origins
and insertions like creating more
favorable uh moment arms or whatever
from what I understand those things are
relevant but when you look at unskilled
exercise and fiber type specifics and
negate skill and that neuromuscular
efficiency and difference in moment arms
you still see pretty big differences in
how much force can be produced so what's
going on there Greg yeah so uh just to
start with I wrote an article about this
topic and maybe like 2016 2017
thereabouts
uh the title is size versus strength how
important is muscle growth for strength
gains uh that will be linked in the show
notes and I also uh wrote a more recent
article that that was published in mass
and was a cover story so I believe we
published that on Stronger by science as
well yeah we can try to dig that up yeah
yeah I forget the title right off the
top of my head but we'll we'll find that
and and Link it in the show notes as
well um but but yeah so like in general
the amount of muscle you have is
certainly important for strength and
being able to generate Force um and it
like there I think what uh what the The
Listener was alluding to in their
question is that
in typically relatively short-term
studies that look at individual changes
in muscle size versus individual changes
in strength there is often a relatively
weak correlation between the amount of
hypertrophy observed and the magnitude
of strength gains observed um and that
leads some people to think that muscle
growth and the amount of muscle you have
is like virtually Irrelevant for um for
creating Force um it also like in
addition to the article I alluded to I
was involved in uh a bit of a a bit of a
back and forth um in I think I think
jscr on this topic uh a while back um
and I'll I'll link the perspective paper
basically arguing that hypertrophy is
irrelevant for strength and our response
I know we think it is pretty important
uh I'll link those in the show notes as
well all of which is to say there will
be plenty of resources in the show notes
if you would like to dig into this topic
uh in more
detail but um I mean I think to start
with it is quite clear that the amount
of muscle you have is very important for
lifting heavy weights yeah um I mean
like weight classes in powerlifting
exist for a reason weight classes in
weightlifting exist for a reason weight
classes in strong man exist for a reason
like yeah there are no weight classes in
the jungle though that is correct uh but
there are in strength Sports and the
reason that those weight classes exist
is guess what like bigger people with
more muscle lift heavier weights and so
if you if you put someone who's 400
pounds and someone who's 130 in the same
division like the person who weighs 400
is g to win like almost every time um
and so yeah like obviously the amount of
muscle you have is important and I think
the the relatively weak correlations
that are sometimes observed in again
like relatively short-term studies in
the research I think that's mostly just
a result of the fact that like other
things do contribute to gains in
strength um so especially if it's a
study on untrained individuals there
will be increases in motor skill that
are that are observed um there are going
to be like structural changes within the
muscle um like probably within the
connective tissue surrounding the
muscles that affect the efficiency of
force transfer from muscle fibers to the
tendons cool like and and those things
occur and they're also like different
between individuals and so so like you
know if you had two people where their
muscle size increased by 10% but one of
them for whatever reason already had
kind of like intramuscular connective
tissue that was really good at
transferring force and they were already
like relatively good at whatever
exercise you were testing um their
strength might go up 10% but if the
other person who experienced a 10%
increase in muscle growth if they had
like piss poor motor skills and like
didn't have intramuscular connective
tissue that was particularly well geared
for transferring Force with that same
10% increase in muscle size their one
rep max like bicep curl or whatever
might go up like 40 50% right um even
even if in those two individuals the
like causal contribution of hypertrophy
was identical you could still wind up
with like two very different changes in
strength um so yeah like I think that
answers one part of that question uh and
then the other part was just kind of
like variability
in strength between individuals who do
have similar amounts of muscle mass um
and so yeah like you mentioned um in in
your answer to the question like it is
commonly perceived or like it's commonly
believed um kind of within the strength
Sports community that a lot of it does
just come down to muscle Origins and
insertions or kind of like stated more
technically uh the the length of the
internal moment arms that
uh relate to the muscles like if if uh
like if your biceps were to insert like
an inch further down your forearm you
would be able to curl way more weight
even if your biceps themselves were line
linearly Contracting with the same
amount of force just cuz that internal
moment arm would be longer and so you
might say that that that that person has
like efficient muscle insertions for the
bicep curl um so yeah like a lot of
people think that like motor skill
neuromuscular efficiency muscle or and
insertions are like really the dominant
or like only factors uh explaining
strength differences between individuals
with similar amounts of muscle mass and
like those things are certainly relevant
and are especially kind of motor skill
quote unquote neuromuscular efficiency
that is particularly important when
you're talking about more skilled tests
of strength so for instance like it
probably doesn't matter all that much
for like a one like a a maximum force on
an isometric knee extension right but it
probably does matter more for the
deadlift it probably matters even more
for the squat probably matters even more
for the clean and jerk and scash like as
as the like level of skillfulness of the
strength test increases like yeah motor
skill just how good are you at the lift
is going to matter more and more um and
like
certainly uh muscle Origins and
insertions can make a the difference
although uh they don't like they do
differ between individuals but like
generally not by a ton um like if uh in
in one of the Articles Linked In the
show notes like I I include some
citations for this but like if for
instance you had uh like quad insertions
that were particularly good um for like
knee extension force or you had quad
insertions that are particularly bad for
knee extension Force like that can make
a difference but you know we're we're
talking about the difference between
like being one standard de deviation
above or one standard deviation below
the mean we're talking about like maybe
a 20% difference in joint torque which
which isn't nothing but you know you
might see two people who have similar
amounts of muscle mass and one of them
lifts twice as much so that's it's not
like fully explaining those
observations um so yeah like one of the
other things alluded to in the question
is just like are there kind of like
inherent differences in the amount of
strength someone has or the amount of
force their muscles can produce even
when like ignoring and discounting all
of that stuff and yes there is so two
concepts just to be aware of um one is
called specific tension that is the
amount of force a muscle fiber can
produce relative to its cross-sectional
area and the same concept in in whole
muscle is called normalized muscle force
that is also just the amount of force a
muscle can produce relative to its uh uh
physiological cross-sectional area which
that's a that's a distinction that
matters when you're talking about penate
muscles but like H whatever like just
don't worry about it for now but it's
basically the same concept as as fiber
specific tension and I mean what we see
in the research is like there are pretty
big differences in fiber specific
tension and normalized muscle Force
between individuals and the experimental
models you would use to test that stuff
do negate things like muscle Origins and
insertions motor skill neuromuscular
efficiency um with a single muscle fiber
like of course you're negating all of
that stuff like you you essentially yeah
uh like string up a muscle fiber between
two little Force sensors and then you
like you have it in a medium where you
can like shock it to like force it to
contract with maximum Force
um so yeah like you can you can measure
that like very precisely and obviously
like motor skill and like muscle insert
like none of that matters when
you're just getting Zapped yeah when
when you're just like testing the the
mechanical properties of a single muscle
fiber and for normalized muscle Force
it's similar like you're you're still
testing strength in Vivo like in a
living human um but like you're
measuring internal moment arms and like
uh accounting for them mathematically
like after you take the force
measurements and you're taking those
Force measurements with like very very
basic exercises where people without
like neuromuscular diseases can like
demonstrate their full strength like
they can't exert all of the force that
they're capable of exerting and like
some studies will even uh use like an
additional kind of stimulus from an
electrode to just like stimulate the
motor nerve to like force it to contract
as hard as so so yeah in those studies
you're using experimental models that um
you know account or completely negate
the effect of motor skill and muscle
Origins and insertions and you still see
like pretty big differences in specific
tension and normalized muscle force
between individuals um so yeah like it's
it's hard to say kind of big picture why
that is like maybe it's genetic maybe
it's related to someone's like prior
amount and type of activity I mean
mechanistically like the the sort of
little y rather than the Big Y like
mechanistically it probably just has to
do with uh how densely packed like sarir
and like myio fibrils are in a muscle
fiber and kind of extrapolating up
within the entire muscle like if if 40%
of the space in a muscle is comprised of
myofibrils versus 32% like the muscle
that's 40% comprised of like actual
protein contractile units will probably
create more Force per unit of
cross-sectional area than the one that
just has less actual contractile units
um so like that is probably most accute
most acutely the cause of those
differences but in terms of why that is
like why you might have differences in
uh like myofibrillar protein
concentration in uh in muscle tissue
between individuals or even between
muscles within an
individual I don't know I mean I do
suspect a fair bit of it is genetic um I
don't know like you you you meet you
meet some people where it's just like
there's no reason you should be this
strong but you're just strong um
I feel that way about you yeah I mean
that's probably the case yeah no I mean
I mean like I have historically had a
lot of training partners that were like
considerably more muscular than me and I
was either as strong as or I was either
as strong as them or stronger than most
of them um and so yeah like I yeah yeah
I mean what I what I'm thinking of when
I say that is like the fact that you can
not do a lift for six months and then
the first day back in the gym you're
just as strong as you were yeah or come
back like 5% weaker or something but but
yeah so I I do think a lot of it is is
an eight and I think that a lot
of really successful strength athletes
who like probably do have a lot of motor
skill and like their quote unquote
neuromuscular efficiency is high like
like those things probably are true but
just their muscle tissue itself is just
good muscle tissue for for creating a
lot of force and is there any way to
like
increase in your like the myof
fibr in your muscles I don't know how to
phrase this question yeah no I I know
what you're asking um beyond the basic
answer of engage in resistance training
um I don't have anything for you okay
but yeah uh generally like fiber
specific tension does increase with
training yeah but yeah Beyond just
train it's hard to
say um so yeah yeah uh I hope that
answers the question it was an
interesting answer I liked it thank you
all right uh moving on question number
three hi both I'm about to have my
second kid and I feel like my time for
Fitness is about to be constrained so
I'm wondering what are the best sort of
more minimal fitness routines I'm
currently following the SPs programs and
doing three days of cardio which doesn't
seem sustainable for the next few months
thanks for your time love the show bye
this is a good question and I I like it
because we have a very specific resource
that we can recommend so we published an
article on Stronger by science um by
Hayden Pritchard and pack not even gonna
try with that last name do you do you
want to try our coach pack patrickus
andreakis corus there we go thank you um
but the article is called effective
strength training for the time poor and
I think that Hayden has really dug into
a lot of the literature
and has thought a lot about this for a
really similar reason to um why this
listener is asking the question and that
like he has kids and wants to figure out
how to strength train in the way that is
the most effective for uh the amount of
time that he has to to dedicate to it
right now so I'm just going to give like
some of the recommendations that were
given in that article and we can link
that in the show notes as well and then
we will uh pass it over to Greg um but
Hayden and pack recommend um for
maintaining strength focus on high
intensity very low volume approaches so
just a few heavy 9 to 9 and a half RP
singles across the training week and
I'll mention that this is like the
specific thing that pack does research
on as well so they're a really great Duo
for for writing this content um so yeah
few heavy 9 to 9 and a half RP singles
across the training week or
significantly reduced training volumes
by like
50% um those can be effective strategies
for at least at least a couple months
yeah um so that's for maintaining
strength if you want to continue to
improve strength a slightly higher
training dose is required um but you can
do that with just the addition of a
couple of uh back off sets in addition
to the high-intensity protocol like the
the couple heavy singles um so try like
one to five reps on the major lifts per
week using rpes from 7 and 1/2 to 9 and
1/2 um or if singles and low rep sets
are not your thing try performing two to
three sets of 6 to 12 reps per lift per
week at like 70 to 85% 1rm and take
those pretty close to
failure um just another consideration
for increasing efficiency within each
workout is the exercise selection so the
selection of any Assistance or accessory
exercises are a good chance to consider
movements that Target multiple muscle
groups and that can give you a lot of
bang for your buck so there are a couple
ways to do that you could do super sets
um to condense work into a shorter time
period so like performing two exercises
back to back and then taking your
between set rest or doing circuits um
like three or four exercises back to
back shifting from one body part to the
next or doing like every minute on the
minute training drop sets or clusters
might also work for you well absolutely
yeah there there are a lot of options
available to you and uh just kind of
high level one of one of the themes that
Lindsay touched on is that there is a
big difference between the amount of
training you need to do to actually get
stronger and the amount of training you
need to do to sustain what you already
have yeah um and I think I discussed
this quite a bit in an article a while
back called a guide to dra trining I
forget what the subtitle was but uh we
we can find that and Link it in the show
notes um but yeah like you you don't
have to do that much training to
maintain what you already have
especially when it comes to strength and
muscle mass uh cardiovascular
adaptations are like very volume
dependent so that's that's another topic
but yeah for strength like um there was
a study from I think 2011 and I think
the lead author was Bickle
um just off the Dome I swear to God I
don't have that pulled up in front of me
uh and you can check the show notes to
see if I was right or not um but yeah
like they they had uh they had a group
of younger subjects and a group of older
subjects I think train for 12 weeks and
then reduce their training volume for
the next I think 24 weeks like I think
it was a pretty long study um and the
like the the three conditions were um
either stop training entirely if memory
serves uh reduce training volume um to
1/3 of your previous volume or reduce
training volume to 1 nth of your
previous volume and they found that for
the younger adults like people 20 to 35
years old reducing your volume to 1 nth
of your previous volume was sufficient
to maintain muscle mass and strength for
again like a pretty good chunk of time I
think it was like 18 to 24 week
something like that which is not
identical to 10 years but is suggestive
that like okay that's that's enough to
maintain what you have for quite a long
time yes um and with the older adults
reducing training volume to onethird of
previous volume was still sufficient for
maintenance although reducing to 1 nth
did start causing losses of muscle and
strength in the older subjects who I
think remember the age I think it was
like 60 to 75 okay um yeah one one
General very unfortunate note is like
middle-aged folks are very
underrepresented in research like
there's a lot of research on people who
are theoretically 20 to 35 like that's
that's how kind of like young adult is
often uh defined in the research college
kids yeah it actually means like 20 to
25 like it's it's the people who are the
easiest to recruit um the folks who need
extra credit uh and then there's uh
quite a bit of research on people who
are 60 plus like sarcopenia osteoporosis
like those are big public health
concerns a lot of research funding lot
of research performed if you're like 40
to 55 years old like there's so little
research for your demographic so well
they don't have time to participate in
studies yeah but but that is relevant
cuz like that may be around the type of
people who are like dealing with young
kids of more like the 40 than the why
they can't participate in studies yeah I
mean yeah that that that is probably an
explanation yeah when you have more
family obligations go go to the lab for
an hour and a half three times a week
for a training study may not uh may not
be as feasible yeah anyway all of which
is to say you can you can cut back a lot
and maintain if you're interested in
still trying to make gains and keep
getting stronger and more
muscular it's going to depend a lot on
how far along your journey you are
already um like if you're if you're
already in a place where it's kind of a
coin flip whether you're going to hit
PRS every 3 to 6 months or not and you
know like things have really slowed down
you might be you're you're at the stage
in your career where you really have to
fight for every inch there's a pretty
decent chance that like a a lower like
minimum volume protocol like like I
understand the research says oh yeah
like you could can you can still do a
pretty little amount and make gains like
that that's what that's what Pack's
research was on yeah uh but there's also
like not like the subjects in that study
weren't folks who had been training for
like 15 years and who were like really
kind of scraping their limits and so I I
kind of think that if that's you yeah
like just just accept the maintenance
life like yeah you're you're going to
drive yourself crazy cuz like I really
just don't think you're going to be able
to keep making robust gains on a on a
lower volume protocol uh but yeah if
you've only been training for six months
or something like that uh yeah you don't
have to do much at all to keep making
progress um but with all of that said
here is here is the recommendation that
I've given for just like a very basic
protocol anyone could do when this
question has been asked on the show
previously cuz I I think this is the
third time I've answered this exact
question but but it's also maybe the
most common question we get asked like
across all kind of Q&A mediums um so
yeah I mean it's it's something people
are interested in and it may like often
times I'd be like ah like don't be lazy
like go check the archive but you know
you already got a kid second one's on
the way maybe you don't have time to go
check the archive which is why you're
asking a question that's been answered
before um which I I totally get and and
do not uh resent at all so yeah like
this is a question that I like us to
answer probably at least once a year cuz
it it's common question yeah it's
Evergreen like people want to know so um
yeah here here's like a very minimal uh
program that you can do it will be hard
but it will be quick and if you're still
capable of making gains it should be
sufficient to keep making gains so
you're going to you're going to train
two days a week one day you're going to
do squat bench press and row the other
day you're going to do either deadlift
or RDL uh you're going to do overhead
press and you're going to do either
pull-ups or pull Downs depending on you
know how strong you are can you do a
fair number of pull-ups already for the
core lift squat bench deadlift overhead
press uh you're going to start with a
weight that you can do for about 15 reps
you're going to do two or three sets to
failure is like yeah maybe leave a rep
or two in the tank on the first set and
really push it on the second set yeah uh
and next week just go up 10 lb for lower
body lifts go up 5 lbs for upper body
lifts and do it all over again and week
to week your goal is to lose as few reps
as possible like the number of total
reps you can do will go down because the
weights are getting heavier but you're
trying to stay as close to your
performance your total rep performance
on the previous week as you can and
you're just going to repeat the process
until you're down to doing about five
reps on the first set and then at that
point you just start over and you're
you're keeping a training Journal you're
keeping a training log you know what you
did the last time you like attempted a
weight like the weight you started with
that you could do for 15 reps before uh
after you drop back to it try to get
like 1718 or like if you got quite a bit
stronger you might get like 2021 and
just basically repeat the 21 reps of
deadlift terrible yeah I mean the first
couple weeks of this program will be
hard that no I have done this for
it was fuing brutal I mean you and you
got strong I know didn't you hit your
alltime squat PR at the end of this
program yep it works it's tough but it
works yeah um but yeah and I mean for
your main lifts like between squat bench
deadlift overhead press you're only
doing like two or three sets a week so
like you can you can get after it for
two or three sets yeah uh and then for
the rows and pull-ups or pull Downs
you're just going to do three sets to
failure is um and just just keep a
training Journal you know how many total
reps you got across those three sets
last time and you just you just try to
get one more rep if you can or at least
try to match your performance from your
last workout uh and then once you can
get more than depending how heavy you
like to go for your back work once you
can get more than either 30 or 40 reps
across those three sets increase load so
uh getting 30 reps across three sets
that might look like getting 12 reps on
the first set 10 on the second eight on
the third something like that so yeah if
if you kind of prefer to train in the 6
to 12 rep range go for the 30 total rep
Target uh 40 total reps that might look
something more like I don't know 15 16
on the first set 12ish on the second oh
man I got lost in the sauce maybe
somewhere around 10 on the third
something like that who knows whatever
but yeah like you'll be getting you'll
be getting in kind of you you'll be
getting into the mid teens on your first
set so if you prefer to train in kind of
the uh 15 to 16 down to like 10ish rep
range go with the 40 total rep Target
yeah just three sets to failure try to
beat reps once you get 30 or 40 reps go
up um and like that's good like that it
it will be tough but you're doing a
grand total of what 2 4 6 8
14 so 14 to 18 total training sets per
week across those lifts like that's not
much you should be able to get in and
out in like 30 45 minutes tops even
counting warm-ups and uh laying on the
ground praying for death after your
squad and Deft sets on your first couple
of weeks um so yeah like it's it's not
going to take much time it does it does
work if you're short on time um and if
you wanted to toss in some accessories
like if if you if you have closer to
like an hour twice a week than like 30
minutes twice a week uh you could toss
in some accessories if you wanted um
what I would probably recommend
targeting with those would be something
for your anterior core and hip flexors
um just cuz they're not going to be
trained much with those lifts you're
doing so something like weighted leg
raises would fit the bill there um
wouldn't it be a bad idea to do
something for your calvs wouldn't it be
a bad idea to do something for your rear
delts and it may not be a terrible idea
to do some like knee flexion based
exercise for your hammies and uh yeah
you'll you'll be in good shape um the
questioner also asked uh or or also
mentioned that he's currently doing
three cardio sessions per week as as
well yeah I'm not the best person to ask
about like the best and most time
efficient cardio workouts um although I
will note that it is probably slightly
different if you just kind of have like
cardio performance aspirations versus
like longevity yeah in both cases like
if you want to have really really
excellent endurance or you want to get
like great health benefits like the the
maximum possible health benefits from
cardio it is pretty dose dependent like
you're you're probably going to need to
do quite a bit um when it comes to
longevity um we we did a research
Spotlight on that uh a while back that
will be linked in the show note
and when it comes to Performance I mean
like just just look at the mileage of
any uh Elite Marathon or and like yeah
it takes a lot yeah um speaking of which
shout outs to uh Kelvin kiptom for
breaking the like actual competition
Marathon record what did he run 2 hours
35 seconds or something like that yeah
absolutely wild um yeah marathon is
entering is entering a a bizarre age
like I I I think we're going to see sub
2 hours in like an actual race fairly
soon which is that's insane to me that's
inconceivable that's it yeah truly
inconceivable that's like uh here here's
here's something to do uh dear listener
get out on a track and just see over
what distance you can match the world
record marathon pace so it's I I think
it comes out to about a 17sec 100 meter
which like I imagine a lot of people
listening to this can can do but it I
mean that's relatively quick like you
know world class is like sub 10 but like
if you're in decent decently good shape
but you're not like a trained Sprinter
your 100 will probably be somewhere in
the 12 13 second range so and there are
I'm sure there are people listening to
this who can't do a 17c 100 like that's
like you're you're still scooting like
it's relatively quick yeah um 200 pretty
Sim SAR like if you're decently fast
over 100 like you can probably do a 34
second 200 once you start getting out to
400 and and you're so crazy and you're
looking at what would that be a 1 minute
8C 400 like that's not that's fast I
mean yeah like that's that's not like
elite elite Runner speed but if you're
not trained for the 400 I wouldn't be
surprised if half of the people
listening to this podcast I could not
yeah I I I'm positive I couldn't do the
800 I think I think that pays for a 400
like I think that's where I would tap
out I think I would be I think I could
go very close to that right and then
imagine doing that for 26 miles yeah
like 800 like 2 minutes 16 seconds and
then like a a what four 4 and a half
minute mile or so for 26.2 M straight
once you get up to the mile like I I
would bet there are fewer than 10 people
listening to this podcast that can throw
down that mile time and he's doing it
for
26.2 that's wild a god a God among men
yes anyway all of which is to say his
his mileage is crazy volume is very
important going back to the question
about kind of minimum effective dose
training so if you're short on time um
you can probably like you could if
you're short on time some sort of like
high-intensity interval training is
probably your best bet yeah in terms of
getting some aerobic benefits in the
shortest period of time possible um
although just in general doing more is
necessary to like maximize longevity
benefits and uh I think it's I think
it's relatively common for like
non-endurance athletes to get too
enamored with high-intensity like
shorter interval training cuz like in
research on untrained individuals like
it's very effective like it it is just
as effective for improving like V2 Max
or uh like running times uh like like
time trial performance um it's similarly
effective to considerably longer
duration lower moderate intensity
training but if you're trying to get in
like really really good shape the
high-intensity stuff is I mean I'm like
massively oversimplifying this but the
high-intensity stuff seems very
important for like mitochondrial
adaptations and just like hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours of
low intensity training seems to be quite
important for a lot of the
cardiovascular adaptations like
increased
capillarization um like yeah ju a just a
lot of those types of adaptations so
like you will be missing out on that if
you're only doing high-intensity stuff
but if your total cardio budget for the
week is like 30 minutes you'll probably
get more out of 30 minutes of high
intensity training than 30 minutes of
moderate intensity training and
certainly more than 30 minutes of low
intensity training so that's that's
about as as good of an answer as I can
give for like a minimalist cardio
routine all right moving on to question
number
four hey Greg hey Lindsay uh my question
for the Q&A is basically what are your
thoughts on training to failure there
seems to be a lot of Buzz recently
especially on Tik Tok and stuff about
just taking every set to Absolute
failure I've also seen some stuff saying
that maybe going to failure isn't
actually as fatiguing as once previously
thought or you could just adapt to it
over time um so just wondering what your
what your thoughts are all right uh
thank you for the question and uh yeah I
I have some thoughts on this and I
suspect that I'll probably get into it
more hope hopefully in the coming weeks
to months um I've been chatting with uh
Zack Robinson from datadriven strength
about this he was the lead author of The
Meta regression that I think has been
driving a lot of the conversation on
this topic and has been um like largely
contributing to the perception that you
need to train a failure or it's like
extra beneficial to train to failure um
so yeah he he invited me on their
podcast to talk about it more and I
assume that will be a good and fruitful
conversation uh we don't have a
recording date scheduled so I have no
idea when that would be coming out but
anyway I'll I'll try to give kind of a
high level overview answer to this
question here but uh like I said within
the next few weeks two months I suspect
that uh there will be a better
conversation that I will be involved in
on this topic coming out and we'll just
see anyway with that preamble out of the
way uh The Meta regression that I
alluded to that I think is driving a lot
of the conversation on this topic right
now um was recently pre-printed the
title is exploring the dose response
relationship between estimated
resistance training proximity to failure
strength gain and muscle hypertrophy a
series of meta regressions by Robinson
and colleagues um and so yeah this uh
this meta regression essentially what
they did
is they found all of the studies that
tested the effects of training at at
least two different proximities to
failure um with hypertrophy or strength
outcomes and uh ran a meta regression on
it just to see kind of what that dose
response relationship looks like like
how much do you grow when you train two
failure versus one rep from failure
versus 2 3 four five whatever um and
they looked at both strength and hyper
trophy outcomes but I strongly assume
that this question was asking about
hypertrophy outcomes because the
strength meta regressions found that
proximity to failure was effectively
irrelevant um okay like I mean for
shorter term studies where like not a
huge amount of growth is going to occur
yeah most of the strength gains are kind
of like skill-based or or like maybe
some of those like intramuscular
connective tissue adaptations and so
like
yeah if you're doing five sets to
failure or five sets five reps from
failure but with the same relative
intensity like strength gains are pretty
similar like that's so yeah I assume
this question is mostly asking about
hypertrophy and what did they find for
hypertrophy so they found a few
different things but people are mostly
only talking about one thing classic
people so they had the the kind of like
main model um like the the one that that
people are sharing on Instagram and I
assume Tik Tok and wherever else once
again we have no idea what's going on
there yeah like I I I'm making
assumptions about what's going on on Tik
Tok but uh but yeah like so their their
main model um kind of shows the results
of pooling all of the studies together
um and it found uh like a linear log fit
regression line gave them the best fit
uh which results in kind of a
how to describe this verbally basically
like the the downward slope at lower
proximities at at closer proximities to
failure is steeper and then it gradually
flattens out as you get further from
failure basically implying that the
amount of hypertrophy you like miss out
on when you stop one rep from failure
versus going to failure is greater than
the amount that you would miss out on by
stopping two reps from failure instead
of one which is greater than how much
you would miss out on stopping 19 reps
from failure rather than 18 I see
essentially like the marginal decrement
gets smaller the further you get from
failure uh which you can flip that
around and say as you get closer to
failure each rep is increasingly
important and therefore it is
disproportionately beneficial to go all
the way to failure uhhuh so that was I
mean like that that would be kind of the
simple interpretation of the main model
of this meta regression uh and that is
is where I think most people's analysis
of it ended um but there are a few
things to note uh about the paper itself
and some of the research surrounding the
paper cool so first thing is that in the
in the paper itself it reports the main
model but it also reports um like
several sub analyses so does the way
that that the training dose was
prescribed affect this relationship and
does the load your training with affect
this
relationship um and in particular uh the
load you're training with did seem to
make a pretty big difference so like
right next to the big main model that
like everyone screenshots and talks
about there were these sub
analyses and with especially like
heavier loads like things around 80% of
1 RM or above um like they ran the same
uh meta regression model uh on that data
and found like much much smaller
decreases in hypertrophy as you get
further from failure mhm which is to say
like if you're I don't know if you're
training with like 50% of 1 RM and
you're going all the way to failure
versus stopping five rep shy like H
maybe you're missing out on a lot by
stopping five rep shy but but if you're
training with like 80% of 1 RM and you
go all the way to failure versus
stopping two or three rep shy you don't
really seem to miss out on much by
stopping two or three rep shy um and
like I think
that I think that like one Dynamic that
that like is is difficult to like
statistically pars and statistically
account for but I think like one of the
Dynamics at play is just the lighter
studies and the studies that involved
training really far from failure which
which like with 85% 1 RM loads you can't
train 20 reps from failure because you
can't do 20 reps in the first place but
with like really light loads you can
train 20 reps from failure and you tend
to not grow very much and so I think
that there and like most of the studies
in this meta regression did have people
training at least like reasonably heavy
and in most of the studies were people
trained reason reasonably heavy they
tended to observe relatively robust
hypertrophy and so I think that when you
put it all together in the pooled model
like that kind of dynamic might be in
play where on the right side of the
graph where it's like you're training
really far from failure it's like light
studies where people are training really
far from failure and not growing much so
that kind of like pulls down on that end
of the graph and then you have like
heavier studies where people are
training closer to failure and growing
quite a bit those are a lot of the
results on the left side of the graph
and that kind of like pulls up on that
end so so you wind up makes it look more
dramatic yeah like you wind up with a
steeper slope for The Meta regression
line than you see when you split those
things out when you kind of do a more
apples to apples comparison and say hey
what do we see when we just look at the
heavy studies what do we ju what do we
see when we just look at the moderate
load studies what do we see when we just
look at the lighter load studies um so
yeah like once you split it out by load
you don't don't see as dramatic of a
drop off as you get further from failure
um so yeah like that that's the main
thing like the the reputation of like
the really
really strong takeaway of like hey kind
of regardless of context with all loads
you have to train to failure and you
miss out on a ton if you stop further
from failure like the subanalyses
provided in the paper itself uh push
back against that interpretation cuz
yeah like once you split it out by load
Like You Don't See as steep of a slope
anymore um another thing just to note is
that when you dig into the individual
studies on this topic like the
individual papers that feed into the
metaanalysis one of the things that you
observe is that going close to failure
seems to make a larger difference for
untrained lifters than trained lifters
um this was something that I that I
wrote about previously as well um
article title was evidence of is lacking
for quote unquote effective reps that
will be linked in the show notes uh but
yeah like most of the research that does
find the largest effect for training to
failure has been performed in untrained
subjects and in particular like the
strongest individual piece of evidence
uh comes from a study by marelli and
colleagues which was like untrained
people doing bicep curls for a few weeks
which like do you necessarily want to
generalize that to like strong folks
doing deadlifts for months and months
like who knows maybe not um but yeah so
like the uh like when you're pulling
together different loads people are
training with and like different levels
of training experience
um like you can get kind of a a
particular pooled relationship that may
not necessarily hold when you start
splitting it out by intensity or by
training status um blah blah blah um so
that's the second thing third thing
looking at kind of the the reporting and
the study itself I haven't seen that
many people bring up like the confidence
intervals and prediction intervals that
are on the chart itself and like now
we're just getting into like stat
territory which I don't know I I think
most people either aren't equipped to
discuss or like don't want to discuss
because they think it's boring but like
it matters right and the the confidence
interval around kind of the main
regression line is like reasonably broad
kind of the the bottom of the confidence
interval at zero R is like basically the
same as the top of the confidence
interval at 22 rir so like you are
seeing a general downward trend of
people growing less as they're training
further from failure but like even when
you're pulling all of these results um
like the
like just the confidence interval itself
does span like a broad enough range that
you shouldn't be like super confident
that it that it is like the precise
relationship that fits the current data
best like it could be a St it could be a
shallower slope it could be an even
steeper slope like there there are a lot
of possible uh like plausible
relationships covered by the confidence
interval and then the prediction
interval which basically tells you like
if another study was performed at these
different proximities to failure what
are the
plausible uh amounts of hypertrophy that
might be observed in the study um the
prediction interval is wide like
it's it's wide as so like the kind
of the the centered uh like predicted
like single point effect um at zero reps
and reserve and these are like
standardized effect sizes like change in
mean divided by poed standard deviation
whatever um is like a hedge's g of like
and then the prediction interval spans
from like .1 to like POS 1.1 or
something like that like it's it's very
wide and as you get out to like really
High Reps in reserve like the prediction
interval is similarly wide such that
like of the plausible outcomes that one
might observe if another study was run
looking at hypertrophy at different
proximities to failure um you shouldn't
be particularly surprised if people fail
to grow when training one rep from
failure or experience like 50% more
hypertrophy then is observed when
training to failure when training 10
reps from failure like th those are both
like plausible outcomes within those
prediction
intervals um and so yeah like it's it's
essentially it provides evidence that
training closer to
failure probably all else being equal
does result in more hypertrophy when you
equate all other
factors but but it's like I don't know
like it's it's it's not the type of
thing
to Warrant as strong of takeaways as I
think people are drawing from it like
they're saying like oh yeah for sure
like there is a huge difference between
training to failure versus stopping to
rep shy and like we can we can precisely
State how large that differ is and it's
pretty large like no like you can't uh
and just kind of like getting into a
much less Technical and just kind of
like Petty observation is like of the
studies feeding into this meta
regression the single largest effect
observed like the the most like the
largest amount of standardized
hypertrophy observed in any of the
studies occurred in a in a study where
people were training like six reps from
failure and the largest negative effect
observed in any study was a study where
people were training two reps from
failure so like just kind of to further
reiterate like prediction intervals
really wide yeah and like there
there are things that matter Beyond like
how close to failure you're trained
which is one of the reason that reasons
that there is so much dispersal in these
data and therefore why the prediction
intervals are so wide um and yeah I also
think that the folks who
are
um like pushing a very very hard
takeaways from a very naive
interpretation of this meta aggression
essentially saying like oh yeah like
like just look at these results this is
the best research on the topic you you
lose out on so much hypertrophy if you
stop three reps from failure versus
going all the way to failure I don't
think the people pushing that uh like
like the people who are willing to like
literally interpret just the regression
line at low reps and Reserve I don't
think they would actually sign off on a
literal and naive interpretation of even
just like the entire regression line
which is which is what they want to fall
back on so like for instance if you if
you went with that matter of
interpretation um you would then also be
signed up to kind of like give your sign
off on the idea that you will grow about
half as much training six reps from fail
as going all the way to failure just cuz
like the standardized effect estimate
for the regression line at 6 R is
basically half of what it is at zero R
and so like yeah you know if you're
trying to grow as much as possible go
all the way to failure but like oh yeah
you'll grow half as much and you'll get
you'll get the same gains but it'll just
take you a little bit longer if you
train six reps from failure like I don't
think they would sign off on that
interpretation mhm or even more
gallingly the effect estimate like on
the meta regression line at like 15 reps
in reserve is like a third that at zero
reps in reserve and I don't see
anyone saying oh yeah take your 20 rep
max do sets of five and that's going to
get you as a third as many gains as
doing sets of 20 with the same load like
I don't think anyone says that
no believes that and so so it's like you
can't have your cake and eat it too like
if you're if you're
going to make strong claims based on a
naive literal interpretation of just the
regression line not looking at the
confidence intervals not looking at the
sub analyses not looking at theed inter
yeah if if your if your interpretation
of this meta is just that single meta
regression line you better be willing to
sign off on the whole line and I
don't think not just not just a tiny
little part of I don't think people want
to do that uh they don't want to do that
I think
I mean I think a lot of it
is uh like bias justification cuz cuz
like the folks
pushing that particular interpretation
of this meta aggression the hardest are
also the folks who popularized the
so-called effective reps model MH and
also like so they're they're taking the
bits of this met aggression that do
seem to back up what they're saying like
they want to say like oh yeah like you
miss out on so much growth if you're not
getting all five possible effective and
for for listeners that don't know what
that is it's the idea that that uh
mechanical tension is literally the only
thing that matters for hypertrophy and
as you get closer to failure mechanical
tension within muscle fibers increases
and only the last five reps before
failure of a set give you enough
mechanical tension to cause a
hypertrophic stimulus right so like a
natural implication of that position is
that zero hypertrophy should occur at
more than five reps from failure um
which is why I say I don't think they
would sign off on the idea that you can
get a third as much growth training with
like 15 reps in reserve yeah and also
like if you look beyond the single meta
regression line and just look at the
effect estimates from all of the studies
feeding into this like just look at the
effect estimates of people training five
or more with five or more reps in
reserve most of them are positive like
most of the studies where people do like
quote unquote zero effective reps they
still grow so like it's
whatever yeah um but yeah so like they
want to take just the very left side of
the meta regression line where they're
like ooh steep drop off as you start
getting further from failure this like
validates our model um while paying
attention to while like
ignoring literally everything else on
the main figure any of the sub analyses
uh literally anything else
so I'm disappointed but I'm not
surprised yes so like that that is just
kind of my rant about it um anyway all
of which is to
say uh I mean I do think that in general
like training closer to failure will
probably net you more growth than
stopping further from failure I think
that the people pushing that idea the
hardest and the loudest are dramatically
overstating their case and I don't think
they're statistically Savvy enough to
understand the extent to which they're
overstating their case um and so yeah
like I I do think in a vacuum um I I
think you probably will achieve pretty
similar levels of growth going all the
way to failure versus stopping two or
three rep shy mhm but I Al like if I
were a betting man and I were to say
like hey 10 years from now when all of
the re like when we have way more
research on this topic um do I think the
point estimate going to failure versus
two or three rep shy like which which
one do I think will have like a slightly
higher Point estimate like of the two I
do think that there's like a better than
50/50 chance that going to failure on a
per set basis probably does give you a
little bit more growth yeah but I also
think that the amount you would miss out
on by stopping a rep too shy
is way less than the people pushing the
idea that going to failure is absolutely
necessary I I think I think the uh the
amount you would miss out on is way way
smaller than the current discourse would
suggest that it is yeah
um and there and there are reasons that
you might not want to train to failure
like I I know when you've talked about
this in the past um it's been like
you know maybe you get a little bit
extra of going all the way to failure
but maybe if you're taking every
set until you you have maybe two reps
still in the tank so like it's pretty
hard there at the end but like you're
not going all the way to failure that
you're going to be able to recover from
that a little bit better yeah so that
was the second part of the question yeah
um and that is a good segue and um yeah
like I I I have been on the tip that
like training to failure is more
fatiguing than stopping shy but but I do
think kind of now switching which side
of the argument I'm on here I do think
that that has been largely overblown
okay um like like this is uh ju just to
give people a bit of a peak behind the
veil um this was a topic we we wrote
about at Mass quite a few times while I
was there right and that's why I know
things about it just reading Mass
articles well and so like during our
review process like I often times wasn't
the one reviewing those studies but I
was giving like feedback on uh on the
articles that were written and so like
most of the research that people would
cite to say it is like super fatiguing
and super hard to recover if you train
from failure virtually all of those
studies do just have people doing a
single bout of exercise well like it's a
crossover stud some of them use
independent groups some Su are crossover
studies but essentially you either have
two groups and like maybe one does a
workout for reps from failure and the
other goes to failure or you have like a
single group and half of them do
training to failure and the other half
does four reps from failure and then you
switch and the people that did four reps
from failure go to failure the people
that went to failure go four reps to
failure like it's one it's one of those
two experimental models but uh it does
only involve people training to failure
in one session yeah and that's it mhm
and I have always made the argument um
like like going going back and forth
with with the lads in the review process
like hey like this is an acute study and
like I think people adapt over time like
I don't I think I think that that that
research overestimates the real world
recovery implications of training closer
to failure because you do it once you do
it twice you do it three times and like
it's it's just not going to cause as
much residual fatigue and muscle damage
the third time as it did the first time
yeah um and so yeah like I I have been
of that perspective for a while and in
fact uh up top at the start of the show
I alluded to one of one of my old Mass
articles that would be linked in the
show notes and this is where that comes
in uh so my article was titled does
Ecentric training always cause more
muscle damage and the study that it was
reviewing is titled Ecentric exercise
per se does not affect muscle damage
biomarkers colon early and late phase
adaptations um so both both of those
things will be linked in the show notes
and so like this was um this was not a
proximity to failure experimental model
like it wasn't looking at training two
reps from failure versus two failure or
whatever um but I think if anything it's
an even better experimental model just
for
probing the degree to which the repeated
bout effect and kind of protective
adaptations in the muscles can and uh
occur over time and like protect you
from muscle damage in in a way that I
think generalizes to other models as
well so essentially in this study they
used um they used untrained subjects and
they had uh they had folks either do uh
maximum like maximal concentric or
Ecentric reps once per week for 10 weeks
and so like concentric that's kind of
the the lifting phase um and Ecentric is
the lowering phase and Ecentric stress
Ecentric strain is what causes most
muscle damage like it it's inherently
more damaging than than concentric
training and the experimental model
itself five sets of 15 maximal
Ecentric at a velocity of 60° per second
so that's like a relatively slow
velocity which like you can produce more
Force at faster velocities with
eccentrics but you can produce more
Force eccentrically than concentrically
anyways and like that that is a velocity
where you'll be able to produce a ton of
force like that that the experimental
model they used would be more fatiguing
than doing five sets of 15 like quote
unquote normal reps to failure like
that's that's a brutal protocol
and uh yeah they only did it once per
week for 10 weeks so they were
essentially observing the protective
effects of only doing 10 workouts so
we're not we're not even talking about
people who've been training for years
and years like training the same muscle
group three times a week or whatever and
they still found that after 10 weeks of
training five sets of 15 maximal
Ecentric um there were no longer any
discernable indications of muscle damage
based on um like a bunch of different
outcomes so like blood biomarkers they
looked at creatine A and C reactive
protein uh they looked at functional
data so maximal Ecentric concentric and
isometric torque uh like the day after 2
days after 3 days after the workout and
uh perceptual data as well so delayed
onset muscle soreness and pain-free
range of motion um like they found like
like B like small to nil changes in all
of those markers by week 10 and no
difference between the Ecentric and
concentric training by week 10 and so
like I don't know I think that
generalizes to training to failure like
I think if I think if you do it for one
session and you're used to training with
five reps in reserve going to failure is
going to beat the out of you and
it's going to be hard to recover from
but I think by like your fourth or fifth
week doing it um there's not going to be
nearly as much of an elevated recovery
burden as you expect that there would be
interesting um all of which is to say
like I just just a as an observer of
some of the discourse around this topic
I think that the hypertrophic benefits
of training to failure are often
overstated but I also think that the
recovery drawbacks of training to
failure are also very consistently
overstated like I I don't think I don't
think you get that much more out of
going to failure versus stopping one two
three rep shy yeah but I also don't
think training to failure is inherently
that much more fatiguing than stopping 1
2 three rep shy like it might be for a
single session you do today if you're
not already adapted to training to
failure but after you take 3 four five
weeks to adapt to training to failure
going to failure is not going to cause
much if any more fatigue than stopping a
few rep
shy that's that's kind of my like like
and like I do think there is probably
still on net a recovery difference but
like yeah I think it's probably
relatively small like I I think that um
the ideas people have about it are
mostly driven by those acute studies
where people only train to failure once
and I think that those do like pretty
significantly
overestimate um kind of the ongoing
recovery burden of going to failure
versus stopping chai all right uh
question number five our last one for
the
episode hey you two here's my question
what exactly is CrossFit good for
besides training you to be better at
CrossFit I do CrossFit and so I'm not
here to dunk on them but I also have an
interest in other sports and as you know
lifting as well as other more sort of
endurance or cardio based efforts and
I'm not sure CrossFit helps me get
better at any of them that's not
necessarily why I do it I like the
community etc etc but I'm
curious what that style of training does
for with someone if anything yeah so
just as a bit of
framing for the claims and kind of like
the chatter about what people say the
benefits of CrossFit are um I found a
systematic Review called the benefits
and risks of CrossFit that included 13
studies that examined uh the safety and
health benefits of CrossFit uh some of
those studies showed that CrossFit
training can be effective for improving
endurance
um increasing maximal aerobic capacity
in V2 Max and increasing aerobic and
anerobic
capacity um they also found that it can
have a positive influence on
participants body composition though
they noted that that could be due to
nutrition changes because a lot of
people who do CrossFit also do Paleo um
and a positive influence on strength
flexibility power and balance and then
some other body composition related
stuff BMI fat mass and waste
circumference um besides the positive
physical effects of CrossFit they they
mentioned um the thing that the listener
mentioned about like community so
effects on mood State and social aspects
were examined and found among other
things it's been shown that CrossFit
training has a positive influence on
motivational factors and the sense of
community and so yeah that's I I just
wanted to provide that as framing for
kind of like this one systematic review
on CrossFit um Greg what do you think
yeah I think that that is all correct um
but much much like my answer to the
question about kind of minimalist
training um I think it's it's just going
to depend really heavily on your
training status and how good you're
trying to get at other like specific
Pursuits and also quite frankly just how
you conceptualize of CrossFit like what
do you define to be CrossFit um and so
yeah like starting starting at the end
like what do you define to be CrossFit
um as far as I can tell like competitive
crossfitters the way that it's that it's
functionally defined for them is just
like strength and conditioning like the
same sorts of things that you might do
for like a college or professional
athlete training for a specific sport so
you know there's going to be like
powerlifting sty style training to
improve like one rep max bench squat
deadlift cuz like yeah the games I think
they've done like a three rep max front
squat I think they've done a one rep max
deadlift they do like really heavy
snatches and cleans from time to time um
and not like if you're trying to be a
competitive crossfitter a lot of your
like quote unquote CrossFit training is
just going to be powerlifting or is just
going to be weightlifting um and for a
lot of the more kind of like endurance
focused events that you might do in a
CrossFit competition folks who are like
competitive crossfitters they're going
to do a lot of training that looks like
a competitive swimmer or a competitive
Runner um and so yeah you could just say
like hey that's just kind of
standard endurance training or if you're
doing it for the purpose of getting
better at CrossFit you could say oh
that's CrossFit training and so uh yeah
essentially if you take like the
maximally wide definition of what
CrossFit training could be and you're
just saying what are the benefits of
string training and
then it's then it's great at everything
and like those are just like they're
also going to do like skill work for
like gymnastic style movements they do
like what but yeah like you could Define
CrossFit training as like all all forms
of physical training that someone could
do because a lot of might show up
in a CrossFit competition a lot of
benefits of a lot of yeah and so
like if you were to Define crossfit that
way the answer is like oh yeah it's
great for everything right um if you
were to Define it more narrowly as going
to your local box and and doing the wads
that your coach takes you through um
then I think the the systematic review
that you alluded to um is going to be
quite a bit more informative uh but like
I mentioned I think it's also going to
depend really heavily on your training
status and how good you're trying to get
at particular things so like I haven't
dug into all 13 of the studies
referenced in that systematic review but
I'm going to assume pretty strongly that
most of the subjects in those studies
were were either brand new crossfitters
or people who' been doing it for maybe
like a year or two tops right um and I
mean ultimately if you're trying to get
in just like decently good shape like
you're trying to in increase your V2 Max
you're trying to improve your body comp
you're trying to get stronger and and
you're starting from Square One
crossfit's going to be good at all of
those things like it has you do some
like kind of heavy lifting it has you
doing uh like their met like plenty of
aerobic anerobic conditioning like
there's it it's it's going to get you to
a pretty good place in a lot of
different kind of measurable physical
characteristics right but then if you've
maybe been doing CrossFit for four or
five years already and you're doing your
wads but your numbers on strength lifts
aren't going up your performance on some
of the more like endurance-based wads
aren't really going up um yeah like
you've probably reach the point where
just like showing up at the box and
doing your wads really isn't doing too
much for you anymore right other than
just like baby maintenance yeah and so
like if you do want to continue
improving your endurance you will
probably need to kind of step out like
maybe skip a wad or two or maybe on top
of the wads you're already doing if
you're recovering from them pretty well
like do some actual endurance training
like do do some like 800 repeats do like
an hour and a half of like Zone to
cardio like like more stuff like that if
your strength numbers are plateauing
maybe skip a water or two maybe in
addition to the wads if you're
recovering well um you know stick around
after class or get a membership to a
more standard gym and like do some heavy
like powerlifting style or weightlifting
style training um like once you reach a
a once you reach the level of
development past which just doing
CrossFit isn't causing improvements
anymore like you will probably need to
do some more specific training which
again if you Define crossfit as broadly
as possible guess what you're still
doing CrossFit um but yeah so so it
sounds like for this
listener if if she's already lifting and
doing more endurance and cardio based
stuff separately from Crossfit and has
been doing CrossFit for a while she's
probably not getting a ton of benefit
from Crossfit just as she suspected I
mean my assumption is probably no but
I'm I mean the easiest way to answer
that question is just test it for
yourself like whatever strength Pursuits
you're the most interested in like like
let's just say that your your main
strength related goal is to get the
biggest squat possible just like come
come before a wad one day like if
there's a Rack open or just like get a
day pass at another gym and just like
hit a one rep max squat MH and then just
like show up to your Wads for 3 months
test your squad again did it go up if so
guess what crossfit's still working like
it is still helping you get stronger if
not or like if it's barely changed then
uh yeah it's probably not doing it for
you yeah and and similar type of deal
like go out run a 5k run a 10K test your
time do your Wads for three months run a
5k or 10K again did your time improve if
so CrossFit is probably still helping
your endurance if not it's probably not
and you probably need to do some more
specific endurance training um so yeah
like like based on the tone of the
question
I suspect that they're already there um
but if you're not sure like I said it's
it's it will take a bit of time like
it'll T it'll take a couple months to
get kind of a valid test retest but um
that's it's an easy enough thing to test
for yourself and yeah based on the
outcome of that test you may say hey
crossfit's still good like it's still
helping me get stronger still helping me
improve my endurance or you might say
hey I need to do some more specific
endurance training or specific strength
training or both mhm now something we
didn't mention is like Mobility stuff
and that was one of the things that was
mentioned in the systematic review it
could be that doing CrossFit on top of
those things could be helping with like
flexibility and Mobility could be um
just going through a different range of
exercises and from what I understand
like from what I've seen about CrossFit
like they do emphasize like Mobility
quite a bit um that could be helping
yeah I I I I think they emphasize
Mobility quite a bit just cuz like
weightlifting variance factor in pretty
strongly and like you you you take the
average American off the street and have
them do a snatch they're not going to be
able to do a snatch no um see I I think
a lot I think a lot of it is done with
weightlifting in mind uh so if if the
questioner is saying like hey I'm trying
to get stronger but what they have in
mind is weightlifting like their
weightlifting training is probably
giving them the mobility benefits like
cross um I will say just in a general
sense like I do
think I don't know like in some circles
it
is it is fashionable to on CrossFit
and I do think that like especially
several years back like I I think the
median CrossFit gym and like the median
CrossFit coach is way better than they
were in like 2014 or something um but
yeah like there there did used to be
kind of a a glorification of like pain
and injury like yeah uh uh pukey the
clown Uncle
rabo um like f folks just like
absolutely mangling their hands
on like really like high rep pull-up
workouts and then being like Oh hey I
ripped 40% of the skin off my hand
aren't I cool it's like no like you're
functionally crippled for the next few
weeks like we we're bipedal so we can
have access to the to these two Limbs
and we have these nice opposable like
that's yeah don't it up that's not
a good thing um so yeah like there there
was I I think there used to be much more
of that kind of ethos than there is now
yeah um and like yeah like it it did I
think at some boxes used to be a problem
of taking people who really weren't
ready to like really push themselves and
just like doing dumb like giving
people rabdo getting them like injured
like musculoskeletal injuries like major
overuse injuries I think that there's a
lot less of that now I think most
CrossFit is like pretty decent just kind
of like General strength and
conditioning and so I think that if
you're if you're an athlete in just like
pretty much any sport and you're like
hey I you know like I I'm I'm putting
most of my stat points into this thing
like I'm trying to get as strong as
possible but like I don't want to let
myself get into like piss poor shape or
like
my Mobility or coordination to I do
I kind think as kind of a set it and
forget it not need to think about it too
hard just kind of like Baseline General
physical training program to still be
pretty good at a lot of things I think
you could do a lot worse than joining a
CrossFit box and doing like two or three
wads a week like I I do I do think that
that would probably be like net
beneficial for most people but it's
probably also not going
to get you to qualify for the Boston
Marathon or hit a world record in
powerlifting like for more specific
athletic Pursuits you will at some point
need to do more specific
training all right that uh that wraps up
this episode of the podcast thanks as
always for listening you could be
listening to anything else right now but
you chose to listen to us and that means
the world to me and Lindsay not chiming
in it also means the world to me she
thinks it's fine um I'm honored it's a
privilege to be in your ears thank you
for listening uh if you have questions
that you would like us to address in a
future Q&A episode of The Stronger by
science podcast record those voice clips
email them to podcast Stronger by
science.com and until the next episode
uh we love you we appreciate you and we
hope you have a great day